Au moment de préparer cette présentation,
j'ai d'abord cherché quelques citations
pour partager avec vous.
Bonne nouvelle : j'en ai trouvé trois
qui me plaisaient particulièrement,
la première est de Samuel Johnson qui dit :
« Lorsque vous faites un choix dans la vie,
n'oubliez pas de vivre » ;
la deuxième est d'Eschyle,
qui nous rappelle que « le bonheur
est un choix qui demande un effort » ;
et la troisième de Groucho Marx qui dit :
« Je ne voudrais absolument pas choisir
un club qui m'accepte comme membre ».
Maintenant, la mauvaise nouvelle :
je ne savais pas laquelle de ces citations
choisir pour partager avec vous.
La douce anxiété du choix.
A cette époque de capitalisme
post-industriel, le choix ainsi que
la liberté individuelle,
et l'idée d'édification personnelle
a été élevée au rang d'idéal.
Maintenant, en combinaison avec ceci,
nous croyons également au progrès infini.
Cependant l'envers de cette idéologie
a créé une croissance de l'anxiété,
de sentiments de culpabilité,
d'impuissance, de l'impression que
nous avons échoué dans la manière
de faire nos choix.
Malheureusement,
cette idéologie de choix individuel
nous empêche de penser
aux changements sociaux. Il semblerait que
cette idéologie était très efficace
pour nous apaiser en tant que
penseurs politiques et sociaux.
Au lieu de faire des critiques sociales,
nous faisons davantage d'autocritique,
qui atteint parfois le point
d'auto-destruction.
Comment se fait-il que cette idée de choix
soit toujours si puissante,
même parmi les gens qui
ont une plage de choix réduite?
Comment se fait-il que même
les gens qui sont pauvres s'identifient
encore beaucoup avec cette idée de choix,
le genre d'idée raisonnable de choix
que nous trouvons idéale ?
L'idée de choix réussit très bien
à créer un espace pour que
nous puissions penser à un futur imaginé.
Voilà un exemple :
lorsque mon amie Manya
était étudiante dans une université
de Californie, elle se faisait de l'argent
en travaillant pour un concessionnaire auto.
A chaque fois que Manya rencontrait
un client typique, elle lui parlait
de son style de vie, elle lui demandait
combien il était prêt à dépenser,
combien d'enfants il avait, la raison pour
laquelle il voulait acheter une voiture.
Généralement, ils arrivaient
à trouver une voiture parfaite.
Avant que le client de Manya
rentre chez lui pour y réfléchir,
elle lui disait :
« La voiture que vous achetez maintenant
est parfaite, mais dans quelques années,
lorsque vos enfants quitteront la maison,
et que vous aurez un peu plus d'argent,
cette autre voiture sera parfaite.
Ce que vous achetez maintenant est bien. »
La majorité des clients de Manya
qui retournaient le jour suivant
achetaient l'autre voiture,
la voiture dont ils n'avaient pas besoin,
la voiture qui était beaucoup trop chère.
Manya eut tellement de succès
pour vendre des voitures
qu'elle se mit à vendre des avions.
(Rires)
Et le fait d'en savoir autant sur
la psychologie des gens l'a bien préparée
pour son métier actuel : psychanalyste.
Pourquoi les clients de Manya
sont-ils si déraisonnables?
Le succès de Manya tenait
au fait qu'elle était capable d'ouvrir
leur esprit et imaginer un futur idéalisé,
une image d'eux-mêmes où ils avaient
plus de succès, où ils étaient plus libres
et pour eux, choisir cette autre voiture,
leur permettait de se rapprocher
de l'idéal sous lequel Manya les voyait.
Nous choisissons rarement
de manière aussi raisonnable.
Notre inconscient et notre communauté
influencent nos choix.
Nous choisissons souvent
en nous demandant ce que d'autres gens
penseraient de notre choix.
Nous choisissons également
en regardant ce que les autres choisissent.
Nous nous demandons aussi quel serait
le choix acceptable. A cause de cela,
même lorsque nous avons fait notre choix,
et, par exemple, acheté une voiture,
nous continuons sans cesse à lire
des articles sur les voitures, comme si
nous voulions nous convaincre
que nous avons fait le bon choix.
Les choix provoquent de l'anxiété.
Ils sont liés aux risques et aux pertes.
Ils sont très imprévisibles.
A cause de cela, les gens ont dorénavant
tellement de problèmes
qu'ils ne choisissent plus rien.
Il y a quelques temps, j'étais invitée
à un mariage et j'ai rencontré
une très belle jeune femme qui a
immédiatement commencé à me parler
de son anxiété face au choix.
Elle m'a dit : « Il m'a fallu un mois
pour décider quelle robe porter. »
Ensuite elle me dit :
« J'ai passé des semaines à chercher
un hôtel où passer la nuit.
Et maintenant, je dois choisir
un donneur de sperme. » (Rires)
Je l'ai regardée, choquée.
« Un donneur de sperme ?
Pourquoi se presser ? » Elle me dit :
« Je vais avoir 40 ans à la fin de l'année,
et je n'ai jamais eu de chance pour
choisir les hommes dans ma vie. »
Le choix, à cause du fait qu'il est lié
au risque, provoque de l'anxiété
et c'était déjà le fameux
philosophe danois Søren Kierkegaard
qui remarqua que l'anxiété
est liée à la possibilité du possible.
De nos jours, nous pensons que
nous pouvons éviter ces risques.
Nous avons de nombreuses études de marché,
des projections de salaires futurs.
Même avec le marché, basé sur les aléas,
le hasard, nous pensons pouvoir prédire
rationnellement ce qui va se passer.
Le hasard devient très traumatique.
L'année dernière, mon ami Bernard Harcourt
avait organisé un événement
à l'université de Chicago,
une conférence au sujet du hasard.
Lui et moi étions ensemble au débat,
et juste avant de présenter nos discours
(nous ne connaissions pas
nos sujets respectifs), nous décidâmes
de tenter notre chance sérieusement.
Nous avons informé le public que,
ce qu'ils étaient sur le point d'entendre
serait une présentation au hasard,
un mélange de deux présentations
et que nous ne savions pas
ce que l'autre avait écrit. Nous avons
fait la présentation de telle façon
que Bernard a lu son premier paragraphe,
j'ai lu mon premier paragraphe,
Bernard a lu son second paragraphe,
j'ai lu mon second paragraphe, et ainsi
jusqu'à la fin de nos présentations.
Vous allez être surpris de savoir
que la majorité de notre public
ne pensait pas qu'ils venaient d'écouter
ce qui était une présentation complètement
spontanée. Ils n'arrivaient pas à croire
que des professeurs qui étaient
en position d'autorité comme nous,
puissent prendre le hasard au sérieux.
Ils pensaient que nous avions préparé
nos discours ensemble et plaisantions
lorsque nous disions que c'était spontané.
Nous vivons dans une époque
où il y a énormément d'informations,
de données importantes, beaucoup
de connaissances sur ce qui se passe
dans notre corps.
Nous avons décodé notre génome.
Nous en savons plus au sujet
de notre cerveau qu'avant. Curieusement,
les gens ferment de plus en plus
les yeux sur ces connaissances.
L'ignorance, le refus de savoir croissent.
A propos de la crise économique actuelle,
nous pensons que si nous nous réveillons
à nouveau, tout sera comme avant,
et qu'aucun changement politique
et social ne sera nécessaire.
En ce qui concerne la crise écologique,
nous ne pensons pas qu'il y ait rien
que l'on ait besoin de faire maintenant,
ou que c'est aux autres d'agir avant nous.
Et même quand une crise écologique
se produit vraiment,
comme la catastrophe de Fukushima,
il y a souvent des gens qui vivent
dans le même environnement
avec la même quantité d'information,
et la moitié d'entre eux auront peur de
la radiation et l'autre moitié pas.
Les psychanalystes savent très bien que,
de manière surprenante, les gens sont
rarement passionnés par le savoir
mais ont une passion pour l'ignorance.
Qu'est-ce que cela signifie?
Disons que lorsqu'on doit faire face
à une maladie mortelle,
beaucoup de gens ne veulent pas le savoir.
Ils préfèrent se voiler la face à ce sujet
et c'est pour ça que ce n'est pas
une bonne idée de le leur dire
s'ils ne le demandent pas.
Très curieusement, les études montrent que
parfois, les gens qui nient leur maladie
vivent plus longtemps que les gens
qui choisissent le meilleur traitement
de manière rationnelle.
Par contre, cette ignorance n'est pas
très utile au point de vue social.
Lorsque nous ignorons où nous allons,
nous pouvons causer beaucoup de dommage social.
En plus d'avoir à faire face à l'ignorance,
nous devons aussi faire face aujourd'hui
à une sorte d'évidence.
C'était le philosophe français
Louis Althusser qui a remarqué
que l'idéologie fonctionne de telle façon
qu'elle crée un voile d'évidence.
Avant de faire une critique sociale,
il est nécessaire de lever le voile
sur ce qui est évident,
et de réfléchir de manière différente.
Si nous revenons à cette idéologie
de choix individuel, rationnel
que nous adoptons souvent,
il est précisément nécessaire ici
de lever cette évidence,
et de penser de manière un peu différente.
Pour moi, la question est souvent :
pourquoi adoptons-nous encore l'idée
du « self-made-man » sur laquelle
le capitalisme repose depuis ses débuts ?
Pourquoi pensons-nous que nous sommes
en charge de nos vies au point de pouvoir
faire les meilleurs choix possibles,
et de ne pas en accepter
les pertes et les risques ?
Et pour moi, il est très choquant de voir
quelques fois des gens très pauvres,
par exemple, qui ne supportent pas l'idée
que les riches payent plus d'impôts.
Ils s'identifient encore souvent ici
avec une certaine mentalité de loterie.
Bon, il se peut qu'ils ne pensent pas
qu'ils réussiront à l'avenir,
mais peut-être qu'ils pensent :
« Mon fils pourrait devenir
le prochain Bill Gates ». Et qui voudrait
faire payer des impôts à son propre fils ?
Ou, une autre question que je me pose,
c'est pourquoi les gens qui n'ont pas
d'assurance maladie n'accueillent pas positivement
l'assurance maladie universelle ?
Quelquefois, ils ne l'acceptent pas.
A nouveau, ils s'identifient
à l'idée de choix, sans en avoir d'autre.
Margaret Thatcher a dit un jour
ces mots célèbres :
« Il n'y a rien de tel que la société.
La société n'existe pas, ce sont seulement
des individus et leurs familles. »
Malheureusement cette idéologie fonctionne
encore vraiment bien, et c'est pourquoi
les gens qui sont pauvres peuvent
avoir honte de leur état de pauvreté.
Il se peut que nous nous sentions
constamment coupables
de ne pas faire les bons choix, et c'est
pour cela que nous ne réussissons pas.
Nous avons peur de ne pas être assez bons.
C'est pour cela que nous travaillons
aussi dur, passons de longues heures
au bureau et passons également
tant d'heures à nous ré-inventer.
Lorsque nous nous faisons du souci
au sujet de nos choix, nous abandonnons
souvent notre faculté de pouvoir choisir.
Nous nous identifions au gourou
qui nous dit ce que nous devons faire,
au psychothérapeute, ou,
nous confions notre vie
au leader totalitaire qui ne semble avoir
aucun doute concernant les choix à faire,
et qui a l'air de savoir quoi faire.
Les gens me demandent souvent :
« Qu'avez-vous appris en étudiant
le choix ? » Il y a un message important
que j'ai appris.
Quand je réfléchis à la notion de choix,
je ne les prends plus trop sérieusement,
et de manière trop personnelle.
Tout d'abord, je me suis rendue compte que
beaucoup des choix que je fais
ne sont pas raisonnables.
C'est lié a mon subconscient,
mes suppositions sur le choix des autres,
ou au choix qui est socialement accepté.
Je suis aussi ouverte à l'idée
que nous devrions aller au delà
des choix individuels
et qu'il est très important de revoir
les choix sociaux, puisque cette idéologie
de choix individuel nous a apaisés.
Cela nous a vraiment empêchés de penser
au changement social.
Nous passons tellement de temps à choisir
les choses pour nous-mêmes que
nous pensons à peine aux choix collectifs
que nous pourrions faire.
Nous ne devrions pas oublier que choisir
est toujours lié au changement.
Nous pouvons faire des changements
individuels, mais nous pouvons faire
des changements sociaux.
Nous pouvons choisir d'avoir plus de loups.
Nous pouvons choisir de changer
notre milieu, et avoir plus d'abeilles.
Nous pouvons choisir d'avoir
des agences de notation différentes.
Nous pouvons choisir de contrôler
les sociétés au lieu de laisser
les sociétés nous contrôler.
Nous pouvons changer les choses.
J'ai commencé avec une citation
de Samuel Johnson, qui a dit que
lorsque on choisit quelque chose
dans la vie,
il ne faut pas oublier de vivre.
Vous pouvez enfin voir
que j'avais la possibilité
de choisir une de ces trois citations
avec lesquelles je voulais commencer
ma conférence. J'avais le choix,
tout comme nous avons des choix
en tant que nations, que personnes,
de repenser dans quelle société
nous voulons vivre à l'avenir.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)